knowledge is of two types one is the
religious knowledge and the other is
worldly
knowledge it is compulsory it is
f that every Muslim should see to it
that he gives the basic religious
knowledge to his children that's his
duty otherwise he'll be responsible on
the day of judgment since he's the
father or she's the mother it's the duty
of every Muslim to see to it that to the
children they give the basic knowledge
of the dean number one
ised the Wess of Allah subhana wa ta'ala
what is the meaning
ofed who is Allah subhana taala the
verse S sh number two is Salah how to
offer Salah the basics of it number
three zakat that every each person who
has a saving of more than the nisab
level 85 g of gold every lunar should
give
2.5% of that excess wealth in
charity is a Praying minimum five times
a
day zakat 2.5% of excess wealth in
charity know Year s fasting in the month
of Ramadan in the month of Ramadan
abstaining
from food drink and sex from dawn to
Sunset and Hajj if you have the
means the health and the money at least
one in a lifetime perform
Hajj that is pilgrimage to the holy city
of Makkah and Mina all
thean at least once in a lifetime these
are the basic teachings which is f every
parent should give to the
children and as much as you can of the
Islamic knowledge the better it is but
the basic is minimum
far the other type of knowledge is the
worldly knowledge
again the worldly knowledge can be
divided into two types that worldly
knowledge which gets you closer to Allah
subhana wa ta'ala
that worldly knowledge which makes you
understand the Quran and the Hadith
better that worldly knowledge which
makes you understand and implement the
Sharia better this type of knowledge
inshallah will help you in this world
and the but if you seek a worldly
knowledge which does not get you closer
to Allah subhana wa ta'ala
does not help you to understand the
Quran better does not help you to
implement the Sharia
better this knowledge may or may not be
useful in this world but in the it will
be
useless
and today we
find
that we look
up to the Western
Society for
education and most most of the people
today think Muslims and non-muslims both
that the best profession is that of a
doctor medical
doctor most of the people
think even being a medical doctor
depending upon how you put that
knowledge to practice if by acquiring
that knowledge you're saving the lives
of hundreds and thousands of human
that's good but if you're using that
knowledge for
example to do abortion
to save the people who have done Zena
fornication adultery and hide their sin
then this knowledge is not good so every
knowledge you acquire it also depends
upon how you utilize
it how do you implement it for the good
or for the bad so knowledges can be used
in two ways for good things and for bad
things if you use for good things it'll
be good for you if
not it will have negative impact on you
as I was saying that most of the people
are impressed by the Western
knowledge if you analyze I do agree that
the Western knowledge in terms of
science and technology it is
improving but where it come where it
comes to morality to modesty sobri it
declining and when we read this Western
education
when you
take Knowledge from the Western
education what will they tell you they
will tell you and you find that not in
Western Country it's even now coming to
the Eastern
country it says condom
yourself that means when you're having
sex
condom mean no problem you can have
ilicit sex you can have sex with a
girlfriend boyfriend no problem but
condom use
condomn it doesn't
say that Z is Haram it doesn't say that
fornication is Haram or adultery is
Haram it gives
you it shows you a
way how to protect your Haram